The Joe Rogan Experience that could be a
thing like you know like they used to
have duels so if a duel was like two
guys would agree like I [ __ ] you
annoy me so much I'm gonna get a gun and
we're gonna back to back we're gonna
walk 10 feet and shoot at each other
[ __ ] you like you're ready to die maybe
you'll shoot me but I'm gonna [ __ ] at
least be able to shoot you like a man
and we're gonna go and do this they
agree to do that again 100 years ago I
think not long ago not that long ago
well it wasn't at least one of our
presidents involved in something like
that think so but if I can't remember
who or any deals behind it
one of our presidents was in a duel
right while he was President do you
remember who it was killed Alexander
Hamilton really that was like the whole
thing but was he even president hold on
Alexander Hamilton died in a duel
uh that's Hamilton wasn't president
remember that we talked about him the
other day drink milk commercials like
Aaron Burr very good I can't say Aaron
Burr huh there's an Old Mill commercial
from the 90s it was a good radio call
who like if you answer this question you
win a million dollars right who killed
Alexander Hamilton they call like the
Alexander Hamilton guy he's got all this
[ __ ] in his apartment and his mouth is
full of a peanut butter jelly sandwich
he can't say Aaron Burr oh that's right
that's right I forgot about that
commercial uh but now as I'm saying it
out loud I feel like he wasn't president
no he wasn't we talked about it the
other day remember someone brought up
that who was it that brought that up
that he he had gotten
um blackmail Andrew Jackson maybe did he
kill him but he got he got but Hamilton
got blackmailed because he he was
banging this lady and her and her
husband set him up remember right yes
that's the play who talked to us about
that it was real recently
it was one of the recent guests
who the [ __ ] was Omar
was it probably might have been sounded
like something he would talk about
how many of these you do what two or
three podcasts a week sometimes four
damn sometimes five on a crazy week yeah
and how much you in comedy
um this week four four nights a week by
the way your show your show killed it
when I was outside thanks for you yeah
and all your openers you had great guys
too President Andrew Jackson thank you
May 30th 1806 future President Andrew
Jackson kills a man who accused him of
cheating on a horse race bet and then
insulted his wife Rachel wow I think he
had a lot of duels oh he had a lot of
duels yeah a few duels no big deal more
than a hundred
what can you imagine Biden or Trump
doing a duel what not every duel ended I
remember looking this up not everyone
and someone dying click on that of
course not they had terrible guns their
guns were terrible you're probably dual
that's just insane that's insane he was
a Savage I think he even had one where
he got shot and and uh survived the
shooting to end up shooting that guy
back whoa look at our presidents now we
had guys like that and Teddy Roosevelt
and now uh did you see the video today
of Biden uh he starts talking about
Afghanistan and Pakistan and an Easter
Bunny comes and takes him away
oh I'm looking that up after the show
I'll show I'll show you this is a show
it's just the funny part of people that
can't admit something's wrong with them
look at this but hold on go right there
but Jackson didn't settle a score in 140
characters or less he challenged his
foes to duels more than a hundred of
them one opponent even died so he only
killed one guy but that was a guy who
insulted his wife however for the most
part people would stand and fire their
gun in the air purposefully missed their
opponent making the duel more about a
test of Courage when one's honor was at
stake or their reputation was threatened
oh that's interesting if you back down
in your you know giant [ __ ] but you
don't shoot at each other like you make
a deal like barely I'm not gonna shoot
you maybe that's what you were hoping
yeah that's a [ __ ] that's quite quite
a risk of take that's a big risk hope
Joe doesn't shoot me in our duel yeah we
were I insulted Rachel what does it say
there again scroll up it says not every
time Jackson lost his cool with a gun
and his hand was is documented but here
are four that helped him
uh helped give him his reputation as a
rage-filled lunatic and a few that left
his body rattling like a bag of marbles
oh so he had like that was a thing if
you got shot back then the velocity of
those little muskets that is not like
getting shot today I don't think those
things are going that fast probably that
last uh less likely to die you might be
able to catch one
and this is the guy they selected as
president so things have always been
crazy apparently yeah but that's a wild
dude this is pistols but back then I
feel like gunfights are probably pretty
normal you know yeah someone insults you
not go shoot it out and maybe they will
become again so when does when did it
stop when they've stopped yeah probably
like the 1900s early 1900s maybe World
War One brought everybody together but
if you think of the United States and
you go to the 1800s what do you think of
you think of wild west think of
gunfights if you think in New York City
you think of gangs in New York right
here's the one I would I remember
reading about this he had gotten shot
close to his heart and still had
the wherewithal to within a few seconds
Dixon fired Dickinson fired putting the
first bullet into Jackson's chest next
to his heart Jackson put his hand over
the wound to staunch the flow of blood
despite smoke and dust billowing from
Jackson's coat and his hand touching his
chest Jackson remained standing puzzling
Dickinson my God have I missed him the
duel's protocol required
stated that oh protocol required stated
that Dickinson to remain in place while
Jackson aimed to take his shot Jackson
fired but the Flint Hammer stopped half
cocked not counting as a legitimate shot
Jackson aimed again
ever so carefully and fired a second
time this time the shot was good and the
bullet hit Dickinson in the chest and he
dropped to the ground reflecting on the
duel the doctor marked to Jackson I
don't see how you stayed on your feet
after that wound to which Jackson
responded I would have stood up long
enough to kill him if he had put a
bullet in my brain
whoa
it's a hardcore man that's all that's a
president right there yeah right things
sure have changed he died later that
night Jackson was not prosecuted for
murder and Dickinson would be the only
man he ever killed in duel something
that did not prevent him from becoming
president in 1829
wow people might not have believed the
story either too you know how that story
would not maybe not got around right
there's no video yeah yeah it's hard you
got to be accountable to duels today I
already killed someone right he had more
than a hundred two hundred kills yeah
100 duels like he might be an [ __ ]
right like how many people is he arguing
with to the point where they're pulling
guns out that's a lot of hundred right
maybe like two or three maybe it's uh
maybe it's them it's 100 it's probably
you but he if he's famous he probably
was getting challenged a lot too you
know he brought drunk at a bar there's
that Andrew Jackson yeah shitty Booze
too
imagine how bad their whiskey tasted oh
yeah like look there's just a group of
guys they're like [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
fight them yeah they're probably so
bored they'll fight anybody back then no
TV no internet oh and everybody smelled
no soap all right everybody stunk
everybody's been so gross teeth were
rotten out of their [ __ ] heads oh my
God imagine living back then everybody
must have stunk yeah well things were so
bad people would be like hey let's just
try like Trucking across to the other
part of the country we have no idea and
a wagon we might who might get killed by
Indians Bears yeah they would fly either
rather sale in from across the ocean
don't even know what was out there yeah
no idea probably gonna die but better
than staying here